has been arrested for carrying out a
vicious attack against america's police
officers
again in seattle it allegedly involves
burning
a police vehicle while an officer is
inside the vehicle
our own rick leventhal standing by from
fox news our west coast bureau with the
very latest rick
wow yeah hey sean in the first two weeks
after the death of george floyd more
than 725 police officers were injured in
anti-police protests and many more have
been hurt since then
including nearly 500 in new york city
but this most recent attack
happened in an alley in seattle this
afternoon an officer responding to a
call
of a man brandishing a flaming piece of
lumber and when the cop rolled up the
suspect
threw the blazing two by two into the
patrol vehicle which caught fire with
the officer still
inside an eyewitness says that officer
then opened fire on the assailant
the officer is sitting on the passenger
side of the vehicle
and he's actually firing shots as the
vehicle is rolling
and the cop actually falls to the ground
luckily didn't roll over
the suspect tried to flee but other
police arriving on scene chased him into
a nearby parking garage
tased him and took him into custody the
injured officer was hospitalized with
what are described as
non-life-threatening burns
his vehicle as you can see destroyed
another example the random dangers our
police face every day and night on the
streets of america
with 32 officers fatally shot in the
line of duty
this year alone sean all right rick
prayers for the
police officers everywhere under assault
of an attack around the country thank
you